In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinek Sadeon from A-3rd, on which we commemorate, the Holy New
martyr Ahmed, the Caligrifer.
Saint Ahmed came from Constantinople and had been brought up by his parents in the
Muslim faith.
He worked as second scribe in the Sultans' chancellery and held a high social position.
Being unmarried, he had taken one of the Christian slaves as a concubine, according to Muslim
law.
She was a Russian and another Russian captive, a very devout old woman, habitually went
to church on feast days and took a piece of the antithoron and some blessed water to her
companion.
On one feast day Ahmed noticed that the young woman's mouth had a lovely fragrance.
He asked what she had eaten, and she, after much urging, told him that she had eaten nothing,
but the bread blessed by the priest, which the old woman had brought her.
Ahmed was then seized with an ardent desire to see how the Christians received this bread,
and what were the rights practiced in their churches.
He dressed in Christian clothing and went to the church of the Patriarchate in order to
follow the divine liturgy discreetly.
At the moment of the great entrance, he saw the priest who was carrying the chalice walking
without touching the ground, bathed in light.
When the Patriarch blessed the people, he saw rays of light shooting from his hands and touching
the heads of the faithful.
He alone being deprived of this divine light.
The blessed man believed with all his heart and unhesitatingly began from that moment to
confess the superiority of the Christian faith in front of his colleagues.
The calligrapher of the third rank, who coveted Ahmed's place, stirred up the head of the
chancellery on the rest of the staff against him.
Summoned before the tribunal and interrogated, Ahmed replied that he had embraced the Christian
faith after a revelation, and that he hoped with all his heart that his colleagues would
realize in their turn the deception of Islam.
The angry judge had him thrown into prison with the common prisoners and ordered that he
be left without food and drink for six whole days.
Appearing before the tribunal once more after this delay, Ahmed declared that the fast
had brought about his purification, and that Christ had revealed the deepest mysteries of
the faith to him, so strongly confirming him in his resolution that it would be easier
for the magistrate to mold rock and fire with his hands than to make him change his mind.
He was then accused before the Sultan himself, and to the threats of beheading replied that
such a death would be for him the height of joy.
The Sultan immediately pronounced the death sentence, and Ahmed was beheaded on the third
of May in 1682, receiving baptism in his own blood under the name of Christodulus.
His body was thrown on the shore in a place that was lit for several days by a supernatural
light.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.